pft on yahoo sports peter king mike
florio top stories in the national
football league and this one isn't a
football story but it is
it it is a tribute to
an impressive fan base in buffalo
that doesn't just show up and root like
hell
and jump through tables and spray
ketchup and mustard all over the place
they went so inspired we'll dig deep
and start donating money we saw it a few
years ago when andy dalton then with the
bengals
catapulted the bills to the playoffs by
beating the ravens with a
fourth down touchdown pass in week 17.
we saw it during the regular season when
josh allen's grandmother
patricia died the bill's mafia stepped
up and contributed hundreds of thousands
to a local children's hospital and now
as an appreciation for lamar jackson who
suffered a concussion on saturday night
peter
the bill's mafia activating donating
over 360
000 to a charity he supports that uh
that helps to feed children who
who are less advantaged and you know
with the pandemic it makes it even
harder and
all that money flows into that that
charity thanks to the bill's mafia it is
amazing what they've accomplished it's
amazing what they do
and uh i have a feeling this is
something that's going to continue on a
regular basis out of that fan base
mike there's a difference between uh
you know the fans in western new york
and the fans everywhere else
everybody has some crazy fans who
you know are very loyal to the team they
have them in green bay
and seattle and denver and and i mean
they have them all over
the nfl but the difference between
every other fan base and the bills fan
base
and i don't want to be too dramatic here
is that the bill's fan base
has a bunch of humanitarians
and a bunch of people who are not just
charitable but they believe
in trying to gouge lamar jackson's eyes
out
for four quarters and 60 minutes and
and yell so loud with 6 700 people
that they actually sound like 67 000
and and and all of that but when it's
over
if lamar jackson uh is wounded in any
way
every person who loves the bills is
going to turn that love to the
vanquished
lamar jackson into other people in the
past who they have competed against
and in my opinion it just it's it's
it's just lovely you know that's not a
football term
but that's exactly what this is and
kudos
to bill's mafia and to people who love
the buffalo bills
for really showing that being good
uh human beings is not should not be a
lost art in our society
and we talk about football being a
copycat sport wouldn't it be great if
other fan bases
inspired by what the bill's mafia do
decide to start doing the same thing and
these
charities supported by players end up
getting
incredible support the lamar jackson
charity is blessings in a backpack.org
if you're interested in making a
donation of your own what they do is
provide
food on the weekends for elementary
school children who might otherwise go
hungry they got 360 thousand dollars
just over the past few days thanks to
bill's fans peter i
it really is impressive and it's amazing
and every time they do it it gets more
impressive and i really do hope it
spreads
absolutely mike please do it donate to
lamar jackson's campaign
all right that's it for this edition of
pft on yahoo sports we'll see you next
time
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports